it's keen on turning all of us into a
puddle of blood for their rituals i have
my best men out there right now scouting
ahead
the cultists are amassing in great
numbers and i'd like to know why
there is a more pressing issue however
and this is where you come in olgram
says that you are experienced with
fighting the ethereals that's good
you'll need all your skills for this one
far to the west beyond the infested
farms and the rotting crop lands there
is an area teeming with ethereals that
we have started calling the gruesome
harvest it is a fitting title as the
ethereals have been gathering corpses
animal and human alike in order to
conduct their sick resurrection
techniques upon them
the barn there has been giving off a
blinding aether light non-stop for the
last few days and nights that is until
today
whatever they are working on it must be
nearly finished and knowing the
ethereals it's something monstrous we
can't risk the ethereals discovering
that we know about their creation
i need someone to sneak in there and
destroy this abomination before it even
has a chance to wreak havoc upon my
people we'll only get one shot at this
so i want someone who has experience
dealing with ethereal horrors to handle
this mission
will you be my champion
i hope i didn't make a mistake by
sending they are in an area we are
calling the gruesome harvest
you'll know why when you see it
so
go
[Music]
[Music]
not
uh
so
[Music]
uh
so
alright
stick
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
my
there was much commotion reported in the
area around the gruesome harvest i trust
you have good news i see your reputation
as well earned the legion thanks you for
your service to the emperor with